♪ (music) ♪
Hi everyone.
Now I was going to talk to you
about my plans to reanimate
dinosaurs with TensorFlow,
but I didn't want
to steal those guys' thunder.
Actually I'm here to talk
about Open Source collaboration
in the TensorFlow project.
That's my job at Google,
to work on growing the participation
and the collaboration
in the project in the whole community.
So you guys all here and everybody
watching on the live stream
are a huge part of this already.
If you saw a slide like this
at the beginning
of the day in Rajat's keynote
you'll have seen the numbers
have already ticked up.
In fact in the five days
I've been monitoring this slide
I've kept increasing the numbers
because the amount of participation
on TensorFlow is kind of staggering.
As an Open Source project it blows
my mind when I came to work on it.
So much of that
is due to the participation
of everybody here in the community.
There are parts of TensorFlow
that wouldn't exist,
many of them,
without that collaboration.
For instance, whether
it's spark connectors,
whether it's support for particular
architectures and accelerators,
or maybe certain language bindings.
We don't only benefit from a huge amount
of adoption by being Open Source
but, as the adoption grows,
this is the way we sustain
and grow the project.
You saw this map earlier as well.
This is just some of the github stars
that gave their locations
that we could map,
as far north as Norway
and as far south as the Antarctic.
And what is really obvious right here now
is that although there is a large team
at Google developing TensorFlow
there are far many more people outside
in far many more places who are using it.
And the truth of a popular
Open Source project
is the more adoption, there's more demand.
There's so much for us all
to do together to grow TensorFlow.
Now, do you ever have that thing
when you show up at a party
and everyone's having a good time
and they all seem to know
what they're doing and why it's such fun.
But who am I going to talk to
and what are they all looking at?
Sometimes a large Open Source
project can be a bit like that.
You want to get involved in contributing
to TensorFlow but where do you start?
You think this module,
this feature over here,
is something that you want to work on
but who do you find, where do you find
the right person to talk to?
How do you learn, what we're
thinking about, the direction for this.
So we've heard some
of those things from you.
We recognize that we want
to improve our openness,
our transparency and our participation.
We're trying to work on making it easier
to get involved in TensorFlow.
We've already, for instance,
refreshed our road map
which you can find
on the TensorFlow website
about the general direction
of a lot of the code
and we'll do that a lot more regularly.
But I want to talk about four initiatives
that we have going
that will enable us all to work
together more effectively and faster.
The first of these is simple,
it's essential community
for everybody who's working
on contributing to TensorFlow.
Github has so much energy going on,
there's so much great debate
in all the issues if you look in there
and the pull requests, really thoughtful
conversations and contributions.
Thank you for your input in that
and thank you for being part of that.
But what we don't have is a central place
where we can collaborate.
So what we'll be bringing online,
in fact you can go and subscribe now,
is a mailing-list:
developers@tensorflow.org.
And that's a place for contributors
to TensorFlow to work together.
So, if you're contributing to TensorFlow
or want to contribute towards TensorFlow,
go and join and we can work together
as a community to discuss design ideas,
to get feedback, to coordinate together.
And many of the projects you've heard
about today have mailing lists
that you can also find
at tensorflow.org/community
Whether it's TF Lite or TensorFlow.js
So that's collaboration.
Nobody talked about the fact
that there are many use cases
outside of Google
that the core team just don't see.
In fact, many more.
Much more happens outside
than inside the core team.
So we want to make it possible
for people with shared interests
in a project to work together.
This is where the beauty
of Open Source comes in.
How do we do that?
So we're setting up a structure for groups
to work on areas of TensorFlow together:
Special Interest Groups or SIGs.
We've been piloting the first
of these for a few months now,
this is called SIG Build,
and it's all about building,
packaging, and distributing TensorFlow.
Familiar with TensorFlow,
you'll know we build it in a certain way.
Well guess what, not every
architecture, not every application
finds that the best way for them.
For instance, Linux distributions
want to build against the shared
libraries in the distribution,
that's not something we do.
So we've brought together
a bunch of stakeholders
of the Linux distributions,
companies like SUSE, Canonical, Red Hat,
companies like IBM, NVIDIA, Intel
to collaborate in a group that will look
at the build of TensorFlow
and make that work more effectively
for more people in the future.
That's just one group, the pilot,
and we want to pave the cow paths.
So where there is energy
and where there are people
collaborating on a particular thing
that's a great candidate for bringing
a Special Interest Group together.
This week we're also bringing online
a group for TensorBoard
where key stakeholders
of the TensorBoard ecosystem
can focus on design and collaboration
and also for the Rust language bindings
which is a completely
community-driven part of TensorFlow.
Each SIG is going to have
a different personality,
a different way of working,
a different community,
but the common thing is
we're going to provide forums
where if you have a shared
interest in TensorFlow
in a particular area,
we can focus on it.
Now I'd like to talk
about the design of TensorFlow.
One of the most amazing things
and the benefits of TensorFlow
is that the code that we release
is the code that Google
uses on a daily basis.
That's kind of remarkable
for an Open Source project.
So we're really careful about changes,
we're really careful about design.
We have a commitment obviously
to the API through the 1.x series release.
And we have design reviews internally.
So when things change
and we have proposals, we get feedback.
But by now you're thinking,
"Well you just said that so many use cases
and so many users are outside of Google,
yet you're having
these design reviews inside."
So what we're going to do
is open up a public feedback phase
to our design process so we can engage
much more broadly with every contributor,
every user about how that might affect
their needs and what their opinions are.
Keep an eye
on the developers@tensorflow.org
mailing list for this
because that's where we'll notify it
coming online
in the next couple of months.
My hope is that this process
will also be a way that everybody
can communicate
and discuss in a known process
about the future direction of TensorFlow
whether you're in the core team here
at Google or in the broader community.
So contributing to TensorFlow
isn't just about issues or PR requests.
In fact, I would say, I reckon that there's
so much more probably more energy
going into people who are blogging,
running meet-ups, doing presentations,
teaching, doing courses,
in so many universities around the world.
We want to amp up
and support the amount of content
that educates and highlights TensorFlow.
So we're really excited already
that so many of you do such amazing jobs
and we'd like to be able to point
everybody in the TensorFlow community
to the work that you're doing.
So there's a couple of things
that we've launched to support this.
The first you've probably already heard.
We now have a blog for TensorFlow
at blog.tensorflow.org
One of the things that I'm most
excited about with this blog
is that as well as important announcements
and education that we can put out,
we're setting it up from the beginning
to involve content from around
the web and the community.
That's one reason we're using the Medium
platform for this to make it easy
for us to integrate content
from around the web
and still give you the credit
for the work you've done.
So we'd really like to hear from you.
If you have a blog post,
an article you want
to get into the TensorFlow publication,
get in touch.
Secondly, and if you're
on the live stream watching us,
you've kind of found out about this,
we have a YouTube channel
that's launched today.
Now one of the things
I'm most excited about in this
is a show called TensorFlow Meets.
This is where we were able to get out
into the world of contributors and users
and really highlight some of the use cases,
highlight the work of everybody.
Again this is a chance for you, too.
We'd love to meet you,
we'd love to chat with you
about what you're up to, and have you
featured on the YouTube channel.
Again, reach out to us
we'd love you to be a part of it.
There is one URL to get involved
in all these things that I've mentioned
tensorflow.org/community
So if anyone's mentioned a mailing list,
or a group, or something about that today,
please go that URL
and you'll find resources there.
It's my hope that TensorFlow's
going to continue to be a party
but maybe one you can find yourself
part of a lot sooner and have more fun.
Please feel free to reach out to me.
There's my email address: ewj@google.com
and talk to me about anything
to do with your experiences
in collaborating,
around Open Source, and TensorFlow.
I'd love to hear about it.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪